a lot of videos out there some of which
i've created myself
talk in great detail about what exactly
a data scientist is
but then a very natural follow-up
question is
what is it that separates a great data
scientist from all the rest
so keep watching and we'll discuss this
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
now there have been a lot of articles
that have been written before about
what makes a data scientist particularly
good or what separates the great from
the good
and i think a lot of them offer some
very solid perspectives i'll have links
to them in the description of this video
but having said that i do think a lot of
them cover some topics which are fairly
table stakes
that is they're the bare minimum
requirements to get into data science in
the first place
or a lot of them cover some more
specialized sorts of topics
which a lot of people out there are just
not going to have to do
from day to day one example is deep
learning
i mean let's be honest there's a lot of
organizations out there that
just aren't ready for that yet or they
just have the sorts of problems that are
not going to be solved by attacking them
with convolutional neural networks
and cloud services are another example
so while it's true
the interest in these grew massively in
2019
again there's just a lot of
organizations out there that just aren't
there yet
now i've put together five qualities
that i think separate
great data scientists from the rest now
this is in part inspired by the articles
that are out there
but it's also heavily influenced by my
own experiences at the organizations
i've worked at
and the qualities i've observed in the
data scientists that really
stood out from the rest and these are in
no particular order
but what i've tried to do here is come
up with things that aren't specific to
any technology that your organization
may or may not use i've tried to think
through things which are more universal
in nature
and that are going to apply to 80
percent who knows maybe even 90
of all the data scientists out there
before i get into all these things
one thing that i would request of you
guys is to please take one
second to smash the like button because
that really does help my content reach a
larger audience
also my youtube content has always been
is and will always be free but with that
being said i do have a link in the
description
of this video to my patreon account so
if you guys would be willing to support
me in that way
that would be massively massively
appreciated now i mentioned that these
were in no particular order
except that number one might be the most
important one of all of them
and it's that an excellent data
scientist is going to be very skilled
at focusing on the big picture so data
science makes it incredibly easy to get
lost in the weeds sometimes
so it's really easy at least in your
head to come up with an idea for some
kind of solution to a problem
but then the devil is always in the
details maybe your solution relies on
some package
and the package doesn't work really well
or your solution is a model
and the model's performance isn't what
you thought it would be
and it'll happen sometimes that you have
to kind of course correct
and maybe think up an entirely different
solution altogether
and that's the thing it's really easy to
suffer from analysis
paralysis and to just endlessly end up
going down rabbit holes
trying to get something to be perfect
but there's no such
thing as a perfect solution the person
who sees the big picture is
fundamentally okay with solutions not
being perfect
but sees how that solution is right for
your clients or your products
needs as well as your project's time
constraints
and they're not going to try to push for
super complex solutions when it's clear
that a simpler one will suffice
so this one is all about having that
laser focus on delivering value to the
stakeholders and where that value is
coming from
it's not about being married to any kind
of tool or model
or process the second factor that makes
a great data scientist
is being an excellent communicator
there's a lot to unpack with this one
because there is a lot that goes into
communication and data science
in fact i've done a video on this very
topic which you should definitely check
out
there'll be a card up above and a link
in the description and one of the first
things i mentioned on that list
is being able to shift from thinking
about technical needs to business needs
some people on your team who you work
with will be very technical people
and yeah you need to have detailed
conversations with them
but at the end of the day your clients
will almost always be business people
and you need to be able to speak with
them in terms of things they understand
and things they care about
and a great data scientist asks a lot of
really good questions to make sure they
understand
what the right problem to solve really
is
but i also think one of the most
important elements of all of this
is being able to explain complicated
concepts to somebody
like they're five it's really easy to
assume that your audience
knows more than they actually do and
that's typically when you end up
confusing them so that's another common
pitfall that you're going to want to
avoid
it's a tremendous skill to be able to
describe some graph
or some output or some model in two to
three
sentences hyper focused on the things
your specific audience really cares
about
and this applies even with communicating
with your team which is generally going
to be more technical people
i mean if you can introduce to me some
new model or technique
and in a very straightforward fashion
explain to me what the benefit is
i'm a lot more likely to be on board
number three is
a great data scientist is going to be
very organized
when i did my video on the worst
mistakes i've personally made in data
science
i listed not creating analysis plans
when i was just getting started on that
list
and that's the thing i think data
science attracts a lot of people who are
highly creative
but they tend to be a little bit more on
the side of being spontaneous
rather than natural planners at least
that's based on a lot of the data
scientists that i know
but here's the thing especially when you
don't have a lot of experience
it is incredibly easy to underestimate
how long things are going to take and
like i mentioned in item number one
data science is a field where it is
incredibly easy to get lost in the weeds
and that's where planning will really
help you out that could mean time boxing
how long you're going to explore
something before you take a step back
that's just an example
one great technique that i learned
several years ago was to really ask
yourself
what does a two hour solution look like
then what does a two day solution look
like
and then what's the two week solution
and something else that helps me out a
lot
is writing out all the steps of what i'm
going to do with my r code
before i start writing a single line of
code itself
that's something that could really help
you from getting boggled down in little
details
and there's other general good practices
that go with this
things like documenting your assumptions
and commenting your code and using
version control systems
will go a long way both for you and
especially for the people that you
collaborate with
fourth item for this list is having a
deep interest in the domain
as well as the business problems that
you're working on let's face it
a lot of brand new data scientists tend
to not know too much about the domain
and their focus tends to be on finding
new opportunities to try new techniques
rather than the specific business
problem at hand
these guys don't tend to make a whole
lot of headway
but fundamentally a data science job is
just like any other job
and new technologies and new models they
will get boring a lot quicker than you
might think they do
so if you don't care about the work
itself you're going to burn yourself
out really fast but it's not just that
having that deep interest in the domain
as well as the specific business
problems
is going to cause you to ask key
fundamental
questions it's going to make you ask
great questions about
what problems your client faces and why
what they're doing now isn't working
it's going to make you question the
assumptions that you've made as well as
the business processes on the back end
that generate the data that you work
with
and what an interesting domain is is
going to look a little bit different for
everybody
i personally really like the healthcare
and life science industries
but i would make a terrible data
scientist in the insurance industry
because that industry just fundamentally
bores me
nothing against it that's just how i am
at the end of the day this is another
one that comes back to
really caring about delivering value
rather than caring about tools and
methods and processes
but none of that is to dismiss the
importance of having a strong technical
skill set
and that's where the fifth and final
item on this list comes in
and that's that a great data scientist
is always
growing their stack of technical
knowledge it's well known that in the
tech world
there is more innovation being generated
than people have the capacity to learn
even if they literally spent all of
their time learning rather than doing
and frankly i can't be prescriptive with
this one and say a great data scientist
is somebody who's an expert
at both r and python or as somebody who
knows every single machine learning
algorithm because once again
your own interests may differ from all
of that
and at the organizations you spend your
career at they may just not have an
extremely strong use for all those
individual things
but what i think is important is the
realization that your learning doesn't
stop after you get your college degree
and it's a humility and a reckoning that
you don't know
all that there is to know you do need to
have a curiosity and an interest in
learning new technologies and new
methods
but you also need to have a willingness
to share your work with other people who
may be more technical than you
and they may be able to think of
different ways than you thought of to
attack a particular problem
and you should generally keep a pulse on
what's happening in the data science
field at large
don't get steamrolled by new things i
mean what technologies and methods
are people using out there to solve
problems you do that for some period of
time
fight through your imposter syndrome and
before you know it
you're probably going to be a rock star
in the technical realm of data science
so that's my five qualities that make a
great data scientist
but i want to re-stress here that
greatness in the data science world
is highly subjective and it is going to
vary substantially by
organization ultimately you have to do
right by your organization and your
stakeholders and meet them where they
are and that's going to look a little
bit different in every single case
but if you have these five qualities i
think that you're gonna do an incredible
job
and who knows maybe you'll even get a
promotion here and there
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it or you found it of value
please consider sharing it and once
again
smashing the like button also leave me a
comment down below and let me know what
you think makes a great data scientist
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data